we begin in Bangladesh where police are
cracking down on anti-government
protests firing tear gas and beating
demonstrators on the streets of the
capital several prominent opposition
leaders from the Bangladesh nationalist
party have been detained hundreds of
their supporters have been arrested
demonstrators are demanding the
resignation of prime minister Sheikh
Hasina they want an interim government
before a general election next year
We are following the Democratic ways for
a peaceful event we are conducting our
event with the people and our supporters
they may beat us but we will stay strong
in our demands We are following the path
of ideals and righteousness
the Bangladesh nationalist party is
leading the protests attracting tens of
thousands of bangladeshis to the streets
of Dhaka this month alone
chaos to in several other cities with
disruption to Road Links between the
capital and other parts of the country
trucks and buses stuck in gridlock for
hours at times protests have become
violent as demonstrators call for the
resignation of Sheikh Hasina
the Prime Minister for the past 14 years
I correspondent tambia Chowdhury joins
us from Dhaka so looking at things
behind you tanveer have the streets now
calmed down
yes it's pretty much calmed down but
people are anxious they're worried ahead
of the election they expect more
violence and rest in the city as the
opposition and the government party both
having a showdown in the state both
calling for demonstration the ruling
party our army league has announced a
major demonstration across the country
what they said is the opposition
violence in the country so they're going
to have demonstration all across the
country tomorrow the opposition is still
having meeting they'll probably announce
some sort of program where they've been
doing that since last month's series of
demonstrations rallies and marches
across the country now today's incident
comes quite unexpected there hasn't been
a recent violence but today's violence
each side is blaming each other who
provoke this violence the opposition
yesterday in the rally announced that
they'll have a sit-in in the
intersection that's connecting the city
to the rest of the country they're not
going to block the roads but something
happened which triggered the violence
there's a lot of video Circle
calculating a lot of chatter in the
social media one particular video I want
to bring your attention that was posted
by alternative media and the online it
shows that bus driver who said that's
two guys with Molotov cocktail in front
of the police came and threw the modern
cocktail in the bus they even said do
you want to get burned by the mullet of
cocktail and then the spared away so
this sort of thing obviously Sparks the
violence we don't know exactly who
started that another element says that a
lot of ruling parties supporters
particularly from the student wing of
the ruling party takes part in this
violence along with the police the
police supports them and that creates a
lot of provocation and obviously the
opposition has to also respond they're
not from immune from violence they also
provide violence sometimes now we know
that two of The prominent leaders were
beaten up one is in hospital the other
was shown having lunch with the head of
the detective police they've probably
been released even the Prime Minister
sent fruit basket and wished him well
and hospital was one of the leaders to
get him well and as far as we know that
ahead of the election there's going to
be probably more violence even the
United States said that they expect the
situation in Bangladesh to be more uh
because as you're talking or running
pictures we can see quite disturbing
pictures of protesters it looks like
they're being beaten with battens with
sticks
it like I said quite shocking pictures
to look at and one wonders is this
Crackdown actually working in terms of
stifling the protests or is it prompting
people to vow to go on
well it could be both in one way this
particular
ly watching is actually one of the
prominent leader who has beaten up like
that is uh really badly injured in the
head now the government has been playing
intimidation intimidation tactics
they've been checking people coming in
the cities and the bus putting up
checkpoint they're checking personal
mobile phone which was unheard of in
this country looking to see if you are a
member of the opposition party whether
there's some sort of videos of Santa
Email exchange between you and
opposition parties that sort of thing
never happened here and also the ruling
party has been saying that we will deal
with you in the street if you try to
provoke us the our government and the
authorities blame the opposition for
obstructing traffic in the streets and
they said that we'll deal with that
accordingly but as we know that the
election is there and this sort of
things are going to be common but the
opposition is gaining momentum and it
will continue to probably protest in the
stadium coming weeks and months
all right thanks so much Tim via
Chowdhury